[Música]
aquí comienza el debate de France 24 Mi
nombre es Ángela Gómez Y los acompaño en
este programa para hablar de la
candidatura de nayib bukele a la
reelección consecutiva pese a la
prohibición constitucional de que pesa
sobre esta figura en 2021 una sala
judicial es reinterpretó uno de los
artículos Aparentemente abriendo el
camino para que el mandatario tenga la
opción de continuar su proyecto político
para conversar sobre este tema nos
acompañan Romeo awer Back diputado de
gana oficialismo y Anabella de belloso
diputada por el partido
fmln por la oposición gracias a ambos
por conectarse con el debate y a
nuestros televidentes les recuerdo que
también hacen parte de esta conversación
dejen sus preguntas y sus comentarios en
nuestras redes sociales estamos en
Twitter en Instagram y en Facebook donde
nos encuentran como
@france24_es y arroba Ángel lagof24 mi
cuenta personal la etiqueta es numeral
el debate f24 en YouTube y también
pueden recibir nuestra señal en
streaming y saludamos también a las
personas que se conectan con nosotros se
vea podcast no olviden que todos los
contenidos de nuestro programa están
disponibles en Apple podcast en Spotify
en deezer y también en TuneIn para
entrar en materia escuchemos el anuncio
recientemente hecho por el propio
mandatario cuyo término va hasta el 2024
que luego de compensarlo con mi esposa
Gabriela y con mi familia
anuncia al pueblo salvadoreño que he
decidido correr como candidato a la
presidencia de la república
de seguro más de algún país desarrollado
no estará de acuerdo con esta decisión
pero no son ellos los que decidirán sino
el pueblo salvadoreño Muy bien pues
vamos a comenzar entonces con las
preguntas para nuestros invitados en
septiembre de 2021 una sala de lo
constitucionales de la Corte Suprema del
Salvador
cambió la interpretación del artículo
152 y esto abrió la puerta para una
reelección inmediata porque es
cuestionable la modificación y la propia
sala que la efectúa y comienzo
preguntando a la parte opositora
gracias Ángela primero un saludo
especial a todos los que están
pendientes del debate a través de France
24 para nosotros un placer poder tener
un espacio para dar a conocer nuestra
opinión bueno justamente carece de toda
legitimidad y de toda legalidad esa
instancia que emite verdad Esa supuesta
reinterpretación de uno de los artículos
que de manera expresa prohíbe la
reelección presidencial inmediata en El
Salvador es una sala que el primero de
mayo del 2021 fue impuesta por una
correlación de diputados y diputadas del
partido de gobierno compartidos aliados
que en contra del debido proceso que en
contra de lo que ya también la ley
establece para el tipo de lecciones de
segundo grado y específicamente la sala
de lo constitucional y en general la
Corte Suprema de Justicia
destituyó a los magistrados
legítimamente electos para imponer a los
concentrados Que prácticamente a los
días de haber entrado en funciones luego
de su imposición cumplen una agenda
particular de los intereses del gobierno
de turno de los intereses de bukele
alrededor de un tema que no es digamos
no hay ventana para cambiar una
interpretación Son seis artículos dentro
de la Constitución que claramente
establecen la prohibición por lo tanto
en El Salvador la reelección inmediata
de la figura presidencial es ilegal es
inconstitucional y quienes argumentan lo
contrario pues lo hacen justamente
haciendo interpretaciones a conveniencia
del grupo de poder que ahora está al
frente del gobierno en nuestro país
viene y ahora Gracias primero por su
opinión Anabelle y vamos con la opinión
también de Romeo Power para que sobre
estos cambios que se hizo en la sala de
lo constitucionales de la Corte Suprema
salvadoreña
claro Ángela y primero Pues un saludo a
todos los televidentes que vean trans 24
cabe aclarar primero que lo que surge de
una interpretación de de un de una
redacción de la Constitución surge de
una sala anterior a esta la sala que
estaba puesta por los partidos que antes
eran mayoritarios que hoy son
minoritarios Ellos tenían antes amplia
mayoría en la asamblea habían electo esa
sala y la interpretó la frase con donde
nuestra Constitución dice que no podrá
el que haya ejercido en el periodo
inmediato anterior que esa otra sala
interpretó que se refiere al período
anterior Al que está gobernando no ha
sido esta sala y pues cabe también
aclarar que esta sala que está ahorita
está electa por 64 de los 84 diputados
electos democráticamente por el pueblo y
es una facultad que tenemos de
Constitución no nace de ahí por eso
quería aclarar esta nueva interpretación
y quiero decir que nosotros como
diputados o como ciudadanos podemos
hacer las los análisis que decíamos
estamos en un estado en libre de libre
expresión pero realmente son las
instituciones las que tienen que
mostrarse parte y hay dos instituciones
fundamentales que han avalado esta
postulación no la reelección son dos
cosas distintas la reelección la va a
decidir el pueblo en las urnas Pero la
postulación la habanado la sala de lo
constitucional y el tribunal supremo
electoral también electo por arena y
fmln por los por el periodo anterior de
la asamblea no por esta asamblea que es
afín al presidente bukele sino que la
anterior ese tribunal supremo electoral
ha dicho al menos cuatro de los cinco
miembros que van a acatar esta esta
disposición permitiendo la inscripción
del presidente Ángela
Anabel usted nos podría hacer la
aclaración ustedes opina qué opina qué
opina sobre lo que dice sus compañeros
bueno la máxima autoridad electoral de
manera lamentable fue la primera en
expresarse avalando esa ilegalidad es
inconstitucionalidad obviamente Aunque
ahora en la defensa se diga que es un
organismo colegiado que son magistrados
electos en el período anterior de la
asamblea legislativa pues sabemos
también que quien preside Esa instancia
fue propuesta por ejemplo el partido es
justamente del colega que está acá
compartiendo en este espacio entonces
ahí hay muchas cosas que se pueden
señalar de cómo el actual tribunal
supremo electoral incluso ya en el
proceso de las elecciones 2021 tuvo
decisiones fuera de la ley es que acá
nadie se le está diciendo que cumple una
agenda particular de X Oye partido en el
caso del fmln es lo que se está
exigiendo es que las autoridades y en
este caso quienes deben
lo que la ley les mandata hagan eso a
pegarse a la ley y al debido proceso la
reelección es ilegal es inconstitucional
hay un antecedente histórico hay
exposición de motivos claros no solo en
la constitución del 83 incluso la
incoherencia la incoherencia es tan
grande en el discurso oficial y en redes
sociales que ahora todo se hace viral
verdad y se puede tener acceso
fácilmente a estos materiales está la
incoherencia del mismo presidente de la
república que en el 2013 expresaba su
posición Clara en torno al Por qué la
prohibición de la reelección inmediata
hoy se hacen interpretaciones incluso
cortando textos de los artículos
cambiando el tema de Qué se entiende por
el periodo inmediatamente anterior o
inmediato anterior verdad y hay
interpretaciones a conveniencia que
obviamente carece de legalidad y por lo
tanto en este sentido cuando en El
Salvador han existido reelecciones están
ligadas directamente a la Constitución y
a la instauración de dictaduras de abuso
de poder de violación de derechos
humanos y acá la pregunta es por qué
justamente Cuál es el interés detrás de
anunciar algo que además ya era conocido
pues ya está han dado en Campaña en mera
propaganda aún cuando la ley también lo
prohíbe promoviendo el tema de la
reelección incluso funcionarios públicos
que es Constitución de delito también
desde la misma constitución pero como
acá No hay garantías de que las
instituciones realmente funcionen de
manera independiente y apliquen la ley y
prácticamente la agenda gubernamental
que desde un inicio tenían claro Cuál
era el objetivo el haber dado un golpe
de estado
al Perdón un golpe al órgano judicial el
primero de mayo 2021 llevaba inmerso
este objetivo que la sala les allanar el
camino porque vieron que era más
complicado aquello que se habían
planteado a través de una reforma
constitucional para modificar estos
artículos que incluso en la propuesta de
texto de reforma constitucional que ha
liderado el vicepresidente de la
República hay una exposición
Clara de motivos donde dice el Por qué
en El Salvador la reelección inmediata
es prohibida y el período anterior es el
periodo actual del 2019 al 2024 que
sería el periodo anterior al cual se
aspiraría teniendo en cuenta que el
próximo es del 2021 del 2024 perdón al
2029 Bueno y eso fue lo que anunció
precisamente bukele Romeo este escenario
algo que sí es muy cierto y hay que
decirlo no sucedía desde la dictadura
bukele sería el primero de la era
democrática en intentar reelegirse de
manera consecutiva en el país sin
embargo aquí la pregunta para usted la
figura de la reelección sí existe en
otras democracias del mundo porque le
preocupa la oposición en su opinión un
segundo mandato de bukele
yo creo Ángela que le preocupa a la
oposición
y no es la primera vez que va a suceder
Algo similar en esta nueva era el
anterior presidente Salvador Sánchez
cerén siendo vicepresidente incumplió un
par de normas no notaría el programa
para decirlas pero por ejemplo él era
ministro de Educación y la Constitución
dice que tiene que retirarse un año
antes si quiere ser candidato o sea él
era vicepresidente y ministro a la vez
Pero él se retiró el 22 de junio o sea
cuando faltaban 11 meses para el periodo
de iniciar la presidencia solo ese
artículo hubiera hecho que él no pudiera
haber sido candidato pero en aquel
entonces Ángela lo que decía arena es
que ese señor no les iba a ganar porque
no era popular Pero bueno por 5000 votos
pero le ganó entonces no es la primera
vez yo lo que creo que la oposición lo
que sabes que no tiene ningún chance yo
creo que aunque no fuese el presidente
nayib bukele la reelección hay que
aclarar que este fallo de la sala fue
hace un año Ángela y ha pasado un año el
presidente
pensandolo y meditándolo porque
realmente Pues yo que logro verlo de vez
en cuando a su edad sus 41 años yo ya le
veo toda esta parte de aquí canosa su
cara diferente no es fácil ser
presidente Pues un año después tomó la
decisión de postularse con esto quiero
cerrar hay una confusión grande y la
gente habla de que la sala avala la
reelección la reelección solo la va a
poder decidir Ángela el soberano en las
urna una cosa es postularse pero
imagínate que ha sido un mal presidente
y le cae mal a la población va a ir
directo a perder pero en este caso la
posición sabe que qué es lo contrario
Ángela Bueno ese es otro tema y es la
popularidad de bukele que está muy muy
alta dentro del país pero primero quiero
pedirle su réplica a nuestra invitada
sobre estas preocupaciones que existen
más allá del tema de la sala de lo
constitucional que evidentemente pues ya
hizo su interpretación y ya tomó su
decisión porque le preocupa a la
oposición que nayib bukele continúe en
el poder
bueno para empezar es porque los
intereses que están detrás de ese afán
de perpetuarse en un espacio de poder de
controlar toda la institucionalidad
tiene a la base lo ya señalamientos que
existen en torno al mal manejo de los
fondos públicos de este gobierno acaso
de corrupción que solo en el marco de
los primeros meses de la pandemia del
covid 19 fueron claros en el Ministerio
de agricultura en el Ministerio de salud
en el Ministerio de turismo donde abuso
de poder facilitó el beneficiar
intereses particulares de familiares de
funcionarios de amigos de funcionarios
con fondos públicos con compras públicas
el ocultar eso el mantener esa
información fuera del alcance de la
población es uno de los elementos que
está de fondo en ese afán de seguir al
frente del gobierno y es lamentable que
en un proyecto político aquellos
proyectos políticos que están pegados al
gobierno actual perdiendo toda identidad
y criterio prácticamente ven que no hay
otra figura verdad solamente es bukele y
no existe nadie más aquel proyecto
político que se vendió de Cara a la
población como un proyecto democrático
abierto
horizontal
refleja una vez más porque lo ha venido
haciendo con diferentes acciones a
través de la militarización y la
invasión a la asamblea legislativa en
febrero del 2020 el año pasado con el
golpe al órgano judicial y la imposición
de magistrados de fiscal general de la
república Y ahora con este tipo de
decisiones donde pareciera que no hay
otra figura y no es es el temor cuando
asumimos un compromiso en el ejercicio
de la función pública en un estado
democrático con reglas claras asumimos
el compromiso de respetar y de cumplir
esas le Esas reglas y por lo tanto estar
haciendo los ajustes o los movimientos a
conveniencia de intereses particulares Y
en este caso del gobierno de turno de
sus aliados de sus Cómplices obviamente
tiene a la base otros intereses porque a
la Parra hay una realidad una realidad
en el territorio en las comunidades en
la población donde hay problemas serios
ante los cuales el gobierno no hace nada
entonces acá obviamente
la popularidad no significa
inmediatamente que sea correcto lo que
se está haciendo o también no significa
que por haber resultado electo en un
proceso democrático la legitimidad es
permanente ese es un paso de la
legitimidad y obviamente es así pero
también esa legitimidad se va
refrendando con cada una de tus acciones
y la población no te pone en un espacio
para que llegues a violentar leyes a
violentar derechos y en El Salvador hoy
es una realidad en el día a día donde se
amenazada la libertad de expresión el
libre ejercicio de la prensa hay
periodistas que han sido expulsados del
país por expresar opiniones disidentes o
evidenciar problemas del actual gobierno
entonces esa realidad obviamente son las
que preocupan Como esos intereses van a
seguir de cara digamos a quienes
gobiernan actualmente por un periodo más
en contra de los intereses de la
población teniendo una situación
económica compleja cada vez más una
calificación de riesgo país complicada
que también repercute directamente en la
vida de los salvadoreños retrocesos en
materia social la pobreza ha
incrementado la desigualdad a
incrementado Y ante esos temas no hay
respuesta Entonces qué es lo que está de
fondo que está detrás porque a este
presidente
le interesa perpetuarse cinco años más
si en estos tres años y meses que lleva
ejerciendo la otros han sido los puntos
centrales de la agenda y no el responder
realmente a los problemas sentidos de la
población salvadoreña y no hay excusa
realmente por ningún lado donde se vea
esto es una ilegalidad es
inconstitucional Quisiera darle también
espacio Anabel por favor Le pido que
modere sus intervenciones para que tenga
el mismo tiempo Romeo también y Romeo
cuál es la respuesta frente a estas
acusaciones de violación de los Derechos
Humanos que que hace Anabel Y además de
eso pues bueno la popularidad es un tema
que que será mi siguiente Pregunta dado
que siento que hay todavía más más que
decir sobre este primer tema
sí rápidamente un ángel aclarar dos
cosas en El Salvador no hay un solo
periodista que haya sido expulsado no
hay un periodista encarcelado gracias a
Dios no hay un solo periodista asesinado
como tristemente vemos por ejemplo en
México
eso no es así segundo en El Salvador
tenemos la institución que se llama
corte de cuentas Lo que equivale a otros
países a contraloría Creo yo que en
Colombia todavía se llama contraloría
la actual fue electa por ellos la
diputada belloso votó por los actuales
magistrados de la corte de cuentas son
los encargados de decir si ha habido
corrupción o no No soy yo el que va a
defender o atacar esto si alguien hace
corrupción debe de ser enjuiciado sea el
gobierno que sea pero lo quiero aclarar
Porque la corrupción no solo porque se
dice o Porque me contaron los organismos
oficiales son los que tienen que actuar
en este caso todavía los que quedan
electos por ellos la popularidad
preguntan Gela en primer lugar por
lógica sin popularidad no hubiera nadie
que O sea si yo no soy un candidato
popular para diputados mi departamento
que es la libertad no me van a elegir no
voy a entrar entre los días que entran
ahí si el presidente bukele no tuviera
popularidad pues no pudiera ganar hemos
visto intervenciones muy tristes por
ejemplo de del senador Méndez de Estados
Unidos donde dice que Hitler también era
popular y eso no no quiere decir que sea
bueno haciendo realmente un acto de de
de respeto hacia nuestro presidente
porque uno puede comprar a Hitler con
allí ahora por qué es popular le voy a
poner Solo dos ejemplos para terminar el
presidente lleva un poco más de mil días
de haber tomado posición Ángela de los
cuales 200 días llevamos 0 homicidio O
sea la quinta parte del periodo del
presidente Han sido días con cero
homicidio no con uno o con dos que hace
de abajo las tasas antes eran 20 30 si
estamos hablando de 0 la gente está
contenta y la gente la que le pide a él
yo como diputado le pedía a él Durante
este año presidente postulese entonces
eh Creo yo que eh lo que debería Buscar
la oposición es un contrincante yo creo
que aunque el presidente bukele no
compitiera la oposición no lograra
encontrar un candidato que le ganara a
alguien a fin al presidente bukele y en
el 2019 el presidente busqué de solito
le ganó a todos los partidos que habían
gobernado por 50 años él sacó más votos
que todos los otros partidos juntos
Ángela
ciertamente busqué le ha gozado de
altísimo sus niveles de aprobación desde
que asumió el cargo y aquí pues
recordarlo para nuestros televidentes
asumió en 2019 y según una encuesta
realizada del mes pasado por Sid galup
el 85% de la ciudadanía o de los
encuestados en la ciudadanía aprueban su
presidencia además el 95% de los
encuestados
aprueba su gobernabilidad en materias de
seguridad
sin embargo usted tocaba un punto muy
importante Romeo y ese la seguridad que
es donde nadie dijo que le sea
concentrado durante este periodo de
gobierno con una guerra contra las
pandillas que él ha mostrado como de
grandes cifras de grandes resultados ha
dicho incluso recientemente que ya los
tiene casi doblegados por completo
pero esto no es todo lo que hay que
decir del tema sobre esta pregunta
quisiera preguntarle primero a Anabel
belloso Y después vuelvo con usted Romeo
porque dentro de esta guerra con
pandillas pues Hay muchísimas críticas
no por un lado Pues están las cifras de
muchísimas detenciones de miles de
detenciones Pero por otro lado también
hay acusaciones de que estas detenciones
por estar en el marco de un estado de
emergencia pues son de tensiones muchas
veces arbitrarias muchas veces a
personas solamente por el hecho de tener
un tatuaje que terminan en la cárcel y
que no tienen derecho a una
representación de un abogado Hasta
pasado cierto tiempo usted como evalúa
esta política Anabel
bueno en primer lugar creo que todo el
pueblo salvadoreño aspira a tener una
garantía de vivir en paz de vivir con
seguridad y es obligación del gobierno
del Estado garantizar Cómo se hace es la
aquí la cuestión verdad pareciera que
este gobierno si no es suspendiéndole
los derechos a toda la población
salvadoreña de manera generalizada no
puede combatir el crimen no puede
combatir a las pandillas también Deja
evidenciado que aquello que tanto
publicitó en el marco de un supuesto
plan que ellos denominaban el plan
Control territorial que era su política
exitosa sobre la cual también se basaba
mucho su propaganda gubernamental era un
fracaso fue un fracaso nunca existió Más
allá de todos los recursos millonarios
que se le asignaron porque al final
siempre el control en los territorios en
los barrios en las colonias lo siguen
teniendo y lo seguían teniendo
pandillas lo que se cuestiona ahora es
eso que algo que debe de ser una
excepción se ha vuelto una regla
generalizada que ha permitido que las
autoridades haciendo un uso abusivo del
poder hagan que personas inocentes que
nada tienen que ver con la delincuencia
que no Son pandilleros estén en prisión
sin que se les pueda garantizar un
debido proceso o el acceso a pronta y
cumplida justicia Ese es el punto de
cómo se aborda la temática teniendo en
cuenta también que hay un uso
instrumentalizado de instituciones como
la policía la Fuerza Armada justamente
que cumplen una agenda en muchas
ocasiones violentando derechos y en ese
marco donde no se hay garantías porque
están suspendidas Ya vamos por el sexto
mes algo que no se veía y si no en
tiempos de Dictadura también entonces
hay una incapacidad de este gobierno que
si no es suspendiendo derechos no puede
compartir el crimen muy bien Anabel
Romeo el de medio el faro Hace algunos
meses hizo una denuncia decía que nachy
bukele habían negociado con algunas
pandillas y que a esto se debía en parte
de la bajada en las cifras de asesinatos
que usted nos mencionaba en la pregunta
anterior ahora teniendo esto en cuenta
pues usted como evalúa esta estrategia
de combate contra la inseguridad y
contra las pandillas del país teniendo
en cuenta además las declaraciones que
ya no son denuncias sino propias
declaraciones del mandatario de menos
comida dormida sin colchones
hacinamiento es decir unas condiciones
que evidentemente sí violan los Derechos
Humanos que deben aplicar incluso para
los criminales o usted como lo ve
bueno primero
Ángela somos 10 millones de salvadoreños
en el mundo de los cuales seis millones
y medio vivimos en El Salvador el resto
está afuera son hermanos o hermanas de
la diáspora pues así millones y medio de
salvadoreños nos tenían por décadas
doblegados cerca de 50.000 a 70.000
pandilleros y sus colaboradores y sus
familias yo creo que hoy estamos
protegiendo los derechos humanos de los
honrados de los salvadoreños que salen a
trabajar temprano de los salvadoreños
que nos dediquen de la gente que le
cuesta ganarse cada dólar Ángela
Imagínate que decía la gente que ahorita
se está preocupando no es que yo esté en
contra de las organizaciones de Derechos
Humanos yo debato con todos y debato con
una señora se me olvide el nombre que
creo que te dije mexicano que está en
una asociación de derechos humanos o
algo así y yo le digo y Pero dónde
estaban ustedes Cuando violaban a todas
estas niñas donde extorsionaban a los
salvadoreños donde los quemaban adentro
de los buses están en vida donde estaban
cuando estos salvadores no podían
Ingresar a colonias Ángela porque tenían
que pagar para ingresar y pagar para
parquearse y seguir los comandos de
estos pandilleros terroristas entonces
Creo yo que ahorita van más de 52.000
detenidos
de los cuales más o menos el 1% de lo
que ha pasado al órgano judicial han
quedado en libertad cuando los jueces
han estudiado sus casos Yo soy de los
primeros cuando tú preguntabas de que el
presidente hablaba de la comida o de la
hacinamiento Sé que suena fuerte pero a
mí no me importa si en una celda donde
caben cinco meten a 50 mientras les
construimos su cárcel porque este es el
momento de pensar en los honrados en la
gente que siempre estuvo del otro lado
la gente que está invisibilizada que se
ganaba esos quincena y en una parada de
autobuses simplemente se lo robaban
después de haber trabajado por 15 días
entonces Creo yo que se les va a
construir una cárcel ya está una de las
dos casi terminadas para 40.000 presos
para bajar el hacinamiento Y
definitivamente van a caer guardaditos
un buen tiempo lo que yo vídeo de la
población para aterrizar Ángela es en mi
departamento que se llama la libertad Es
que la gente ha dejado de pagar
extorsiones la gente se siente más
segura el transporte Ángela pagaba cerca
de 5 millones de dólares mensuales en
extorsión y ellos mismos no es el
presidente ni tu servidor ellos como
asociación de transportistas han dicho
hace unas dos o tres semanas que se les
ha reducido más del 95% de lo que ellos
pagaban en extorsión
muy bien Vamos a cambiar de tema porque
de pandillas podríamos probablemente
quedarnos hablando muchísimo más tiempo
pero pero ya vamos llegando a la última
parte del programa y hay un tema que no
quiero dejar por fuera y es el bitcoin
fue establecida como moneda en curso
legal hace poco más de un año por el
presidente nayib bukele Romeo y comienzo
Está también con usted porque para
muchos es una política que ha sido
considerada fallida hoy en día no se
considera que esté bien establecida que
la gente la utilice muchos
establecimientos que hace un año
empezaron digamos con emoción a poner
sus letreros de se acepta bitcoin pues
hoy los han retirado y pues bueno Esto
además de de los riesgos que tiene
instaurar una criptomoneda como moneda
de curso legal Qué opina usted de esta
política Romeo
Yo creo que el tema bitcoin que es el
único tema que yo veo como diputado que
me gusta hacer transparente el que es un
poquito más confuso para la población
hay que aclarar algo es un es una
tercera moneda de curso legal en El
Salvador Ya teníamos el colón nuestra
moneda
histórica
incorporó Un gobierno de arena del dólar
y hoy hemos incorporado el bitcoin no se
ha quitado el dólar no se ha quitado
nada es una moneda adicional y creo que
los efectos que se buscan y que se están
logrando son macroeconómicos por ejemplo
el fondo monetario internacional ha
reconocido que se ha aumentado el
turismo en El Salvador gracias al uso
del bitcoin hay gente que viene a
invertir o a gastar en bitcoin el
salvadoreño no lo usa mucho todavía en
las remesas un 2% lo está ocupando para
remesar Ojalá que después fuera sea más
porque no tiene costo pero yo creo que a
fin de cuentas
es un tema complejo Y si la población no
lo conoce mucho prefieren usarlo pero
están en su libertad tenemos Tres
monedas para elegir para usar y no hay
una imposición de que se use el bitcoin
Entonces yo creo que ese camino va muy
lento y la guerra de Rusia Ucrania hizo
también que el bitcoin y otras
criptomonedas incluyendo el dólar Ángel
así Tú lo ves hoy el dólar está mucho
más débil Comparado con la moneda rusa
entonces gracias a Dios es una de
nuestras Tres monedas de curso legal
Claro pero de todas maneras Usted tiene
toda la razón la gente no está obligado
a utilizar el bitcoin de como moneda de
curso legal si no quiere pero pero es
que tampoco tienen una un grueso de la
población la infraestructura para
utilizarlo y dicho esto pues establecer
el bitcoin como moneda en curso legal
también implica una inversión por parte
del gobierno entonces Dónde quedan esas
dos cosas
no pero mira si se ocupa la verdad que
cuando han venido amigos o vienen
periodistas yo me llevo muy bien con
periodistas que son de Estados Unidos y
vienen yo los llevo los diferentes
almacenes Grandes medianos pequeños
Ángela y ahí está la posibilidad y poder
pagar en visto en lo que pasa que es
complejo recordemos Que
la moneda como tal o sea en El Salvador
por lo menos llevamos 80 años
bancarizados y aún así después de 80
años solo el 25% de la población ocupan
esta forma la parte de la banca Entonces
no va a ser que en un año vamos a romper
los mitos históricos y vamos a tener a
todos usando el bitcoin en el que lo
quiera usar lo puede usar y el que no no
y hay que aclarar algo no se aprobó el
bitcoin para efectos de estar viendo si
uno gana o pierde con el bitcoin o sea
eso no se necesitaba una ley Ángela el
bitcoin se ha hecho para otra cosa el
que quiera comprar discos para ver si va
a ganar Pues si tiene dinero lo puede
hacer pero no es esa razón Anabel su
respuesta
Bueno creo que inmerso de lo que ya
decía el colega hay claros ejemplos del
por qué esa es una de las decisiones más
irracionales que ha tenido este gobierno
no corresponde a la realidad de la
economía de la familia salvadoreñas y lo
que es peor que se han utilizado
recursos públicos primero para tratar de
promover e incentivar el uso y vemos
cómo ha sido un fracaso porque ya más de
un año de haber entrado en vigencia la
población no lo utiliza y además aquello
que se utilizó en la campaña para tratar
de supuestamente hacer ver que era algo
bueno y positivo tampoco ha resultado
que es el envío de la remesa y lo son
dos públicos que sean orientado a ese
juego de azar Que obviamente hoy ha
perdido más de la mitad de su valor
verdad porque el gobierno compró incluso
arriba de 50.000 En algunos momentos y
ahora el valor al menos en esta semana
ha estado fluctuando a cifras baja
récord por lo menos en los últimos años
y por lo tanto el costo de oportunidad
de tener dinero público ahí existiendo
otras prioridades en la población
salvadoreña es una decisión que no se
puede ver como una política pública
acertada carece totalmente de una
justificación y obviamente hay algunos
que incluso votaron sin tener claro de
qué se trataba ha habido otros colegas
diputados que han dicho Ah no yo voté
pero no sé qué es no sé cómo funciona si
desde el esquema privado y de aquellos
que tienen dinero para poder estar en
ese juego tan especulativo y volátil
pues que lo hagan pero los recursos
públicos y de y declarar la moneda de
curso legal ha traído costos graves
porque al final también son elementos
que las calificadoras de riesgo los
mismos organismos multilaterales que en
algún momento pueden financiar con
fondos ciertos programas o proyectos lo
han dejado de hacer por cuestionar y
señalar el tipo de decisiones como en la
adopción del bitcoin perdón como moneda
de curso legal bien Ya llegamos a la
última parte del programa solamente nos
resta una pregunta más para que sea las
conclusiones de cada uno de ustedes
tenemos pocos minutos y bueno lo cierto
aquí Romeo es que bukele dice que él
desea continuar con lo que inició en el
año 2019 Cuáles son para usted esas
políticas destacables que valdría la
pena sostener
bueno en primer lugar Ángela sin
seguridad no puede haber ninguna otra
política que funcione porque no puedes
tener un pueblo prosperando pero que te
estén robando o sea lo primero es la
seguridad creo que se ha invertido
bastante en salud nos tocamos el tema
pero en salud El Salvador ha sido
reconocido por la Organización Mundial
de salud como uno de los que mejor pudo
luchar contra la pandemia del covid eso
también se nos quedó por fuera y es el
tema de salud pues yo quiero que en
materia de seguridad de salud de
Educación sigan estos estos ejes y hay
que entrarle otros temas que vienen
pendientes como son las pensiones y como
son algunas otras cosas que deben de
amarrar ya lo que significa una sociedad
que se vaya transformando o sea primero
tenemos que estar bien que sería de
seguridad de Salud Educación un pueblo
educado puede accesar a algo más y a
veces le llamamos desde el presidente
para abajo a a esto le llamamos el
intento de lograr una nueva Singapur o
una Singapur en en América que creo que
si es posible y para allá vamos Ángela
y Anabel sus conclusiones porque no más
la política de nayib bukele
bueno Yo solo quiero decir porque no lo
dije en el entorno a la seguridad que
todavía estamos esperando que el
gobierno aclare esos señalamientos de
los vínculos de sus funcionarios con los
grupos criminales y todo lo que ha
estado detrás de este tema no es la
única vía el tema que ahora haces como
se está abordando la seguridad pública y
otros problemas de raíz que no se están
atendiendo principalmente
económicos la migración la desigualdad
que son en el día a día problemas que
quejan a nuestra gente y por lo tanto es
complejo porque al final uno concluye
que el interés de perpetuarse un periodo
más en el poder solamente tiene a la
base la intención de seguir desde una
perspectiva sin transparencia sin rendir
cuentas abusando del Poder y abusando de
los recursos públicos nos queda todavía
un camino evidente hasta el 2024 y
mientras tanto la discusión no
continuará también aquí en el France 24
así como lo hace en El Salvador gracias
a nuestros invitados por estar con
nosotros y por brindarnos sus puntos de
vista sobre lo que ha sido hasta ahora
el gobierno bukele y lo que podría ser
verlo en una reelección consecutiva la
primera desde tiempos de Dictadura en el
país gracias a ustedes sigan en Francia
24 y en francés 24.com
[Música]